hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and I'm John today we're gonna check out
this trending video right here that I
really want to see cuz I grew up on this
guy's movies Bruce Lee light sabers
scene recreation oh boy that sounds cool
and Thank You after-effects yeah this
sounds that sounds really cool but I
want to give a mention that we're gonna
do a page from the day shout out for JT
today Justin Timberlake is a patron oh
yeah this is from the channel Patrick
nan
[Music]
fists of fury classic you know Jackie
chanted a sequel to this that I think
it's a colossal II poor idea but I think
they're really cool know if you can
handle it watch Bruce Lee do it Oh
[Music]
oh dude dude that is awesome that was
badass now there are so many movies I
want to see redouble yeah just that
opening image with the bad guy having
the red lightsaber was so cool I didn't
expect the Nunchuk lightsabers to come
in because I've always thought that you
should they should attempt to do
numchuck lightsabers nunchuck
lightsabers what you're gonna hate
yourself well no I always imagined that
you would have armor a certain type of
armor word doesn't get it where you
don't hurt yourself with it like no
matter how big your nunchuck is though
like they they hit you constantly for
this video I thought that was really
cool yeah this is a fantasy it's super
cool I like he's got the yellow
lightsaber yeah I've never seen one of
those before
see I feel like now there's gonna be a
lot of Star Wars fans in the comment box
like debating the legitimacy of these
yeah this is a classic Bruce Lee movie
actually in the next shot when the guy
in or later shot when he gets kicked you
for the bad guy flash through the wall
and then the guy who did the flying was
Jackie Chan oh yeah for you yeah and the
Jackie Chan started the new Fist of Fury
which is essentially the same movies
before Jackie Chan was able to redefine
his own image and make his own name when
they were just trying to make him
another Bruce Lee that was really cool I
don't know I thought that was awesome
and the seeing him with the nunchuck
lightsabers I thought was sweet this is
one of my favorite trappings of the
future all right well hey shout out
today for JT JT the man from Hawaii I
wanted to give you a shout out today
because in this video Bruce Lee is a
Chinese guy and the bad guys a Japanese
guy and I know you're Japanese yes so
you're a bad guy or a bad guy now cuz
Bruce Lee would have kicked your ass
Jason didn't actually hate Japanese
people that was just a movie back now JT
I wanted
a shout out today because you're a very
special guy to us I feel like whenever
we do Google Hangouts with you for some
reason even though you're one of the
quieter guys I tend to come up with like
random ideas of things I like to do
videos on I think two times now I've
come up with like hey I have a story
idea I just wanna throw your way or hey
I have segment ideas I want to throw it
you're wet or I want to implement this
into the channel so there's something
about you JT that gets my brain thinking
yeah of ideas
yeah guys so dude thank you I don't know
what you do but you've got a gift my
friend it's got a gift it's just all
that thoughtful consideration that he
offers each time you know the way he
really thinks about everything and like
responds to you I feel like it's
conducive to to being a good sounding
board you know good collaborator I want
to make this clear to Japanese people or
not bad people that we know of I am
kidding all right guys well thanks for
tuning in you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell of
notification belch and check out our
patreon were doing full-length TV show
reactions on their music videos and
weekly Q&A video responses so go ahead
check it out got a lot over 250
exclusive posts